tout bon scénario nécessite un vilain et
dans le procès de johnny depp et amber
heard la méchante était choisie d'avancé
l'acteur poursuit son ex-femme en
diffamation après qu'il eut t'écris
publiquement avoir été victime de
violences conjugales johnny depp nie
avoir été violent et affirme que c'est
lui la victime l'actrice le poursuit à
son tour le procès lève le voile sur la
relation toxique sur fond d'abus
d'alcool et de drogue l'audition alors
que les fans de johnny depp du témoigne
un amour inconditionnel
les réseaux sociaux ont explosé de haine
envers l'actrice j'en ai marre de voir
sa gueule de menteur c'est une grande
malade cette femme est une vipère son
venin très dangereux parce que des
personnes qui lisent des commentaires
envers madame hearts après les
décourager justement porté plainte
pourquoi parce que on l'a rabais sont la
ridiculise on en fait des mines s'est
rendu vraiment là si c'est un peu
n'importe qui des stéréotypes que le
mouvement moi aussi avait tenté de
chasser se défend elle rétorque si on va
s'attendre à ce qu'une victime
leur piteuse est-ce qu'une victime
collabore en tout point avec le système
de justice alors que c'est pas
nécessairement sur la réalité johnny
depp aurait remporté l'opinion publique
grâce à sa notoriété et aux appuis qu'il
a reçue contre est cette affaire comme
un feuilleton je trouve avec beaucoup
moins de
sensibilité
d'autres histoires mis tout ce qu'on
connaît je pense que par exemple les
victimes de rabin steen on est beaucoup
plus de sympathie je pense que les
victimes de bill cosby ion est beaucoup
plus de sympathie le manque de décorum
ferait aussi perdre de vue le sérieux du
processus judiciaire selon cette avocate
le fait que la juge a l'air d'avoir rien
à dire en affaires et le pot de notes et
le portail et la posture la nonchalance
dans la posture le fait qu'ils portent
des lunettes fumées j'ai pas compris sol
et dernièrement on a vu à la fin de son
témoignage son avocat venir le féliciter
mais en lui faisant une un câlin l'a
vraiment intense j'ai trouvé ça choquant
presque perturbant c'est comme une
amourette naissance une anecdote digne
d'un roman savant dont les internautes
se régale friande une finale en conte de
fée pour un christ de procès spectacle
dure
ici genève garon radio canada montréal